most of the price increases we've seen
are were expected and are expected to be
temporary these bottlenecks and price
spikes will reduce as our economy
continues to heal i hear republicans say
today that
my talking about this strong record
shows that i don't understand or that
i'm not focused on inflation
malarkey
malarkey
just like joe his promises about
inflation didn't age well price is
rocketing to the highest level in 40
years increasing a whopping 7 in
december from just a year ago but joe
claims he's making progress insisting
that soaring food and gas prices are
going down and that the surge in the
cost of living is merely a global
problem and it isn't just things costing
a lot more it's whether or not you can
even find what you're looking for the
president's bare shelves problems still
not going away as shoppers compare
what's going on to the soviet union
despite that transportation secretary
pete butterjudge is doing a supply chain
crisis victory lap
one of the reasons why christmas was not
in fact canceled is that ports like l.a
and long beach moved record levels of
goods allowing an all-time record high
in terms of retail sales this holiday
season considering the pressures that
this country and this community these
communities have been under that is an
extraordinary achievement
he saved christmas
congratulations first to judge jeanine
who is now permanent uh panelist on the
five now you can afford a complete dress
not just uh
half a dress
very racy judge it's not racy at all
it's got patches in it yes yes i know
which i know what you're up to yeah i
know you're trying to distract me and it
worked
so judge if inflation's at a 40-year
high but it's amazing how like the media
especially in the dems they're not that
concerned are you surprised by that you
know what i'm convinced that they should
be teaching a class into how to turn a
negative into a positive i've never seen
anything like it this is a nightmare for
ordinary americans but to them it's a
dream this guy buddha judge who's been
home on parental leave is now coming out
and saying i'm you know i saved
christmas for you you should be bowing
at my feet the mayor called him the man
who saved christmas joe biden is
claiming it blaming it on the global
problem and joe biden said thank
goodness for my american rescue plan and
all of you stop worrying about it it's
only transitory we know it's not
transitory and here's the bottom line
the more they talk more americans are
going to be able to buy less with the
money that they make and they can talk
all they want about increase in wages
and all this you can't afford to buy
what you bought a year ago you want to
buy a used car it's 37 higher than it
was last year you want to buy you want
to buy meat you want to buy gas it's 50
don't give me a half a percent we're
doing good they're doing terrible and
you know who predicted this who donald
trump
you know i didn't see that coming judge
i didn't see that coming
you know also congratulations to geraldo
who has also been made a host thank you
with jessica and harold in the in what
we call the liberal seat now you can
finally maybe you can afford that mini
cooper you've been waiting for
it came it came oh it did it did so you
were no wonder you think the economy is
going great geraldo because you got your
mini cooper
i think the economy is doing
okay if you look at the stock market the
stock market doesn't lie look at
unemployment 3.9 percent the lowest in a
very long time i think that the concern
over inflation might be over might be
inflated so to speak uh look at wages
wages have been suppressed for many many
years remember the 15 an hour crusade
that was going nowhere now you can't get
a dishwasher around these parts for less
than 16 17 18
an hour so i think that some of this
inflation was was overdue i think that
the uh you know the most egregious price
increases will level off uh seven
percent is distressing but i think it's
temporary i think this too shall pass
and the fact of the matter is too many
americans were working for too little
money right yeah this too shall pass we
keep hearing that but you got to do
something to make it pass you can't just
say that as your strategy dana
congratulations on absolutely nothing
thank you you did not get promoted you
didn't get a job
but that's okay you know people are
accusing the president of being out of
touch which is ironic because he's so
touchy feely
wouldn't it be great if it was the
opposite where he could feel our pain
and not our teenager's shoulders
that is a very good
thinking there greg
obviously i'm blushing a little bit
behalf of the president um here's the
thing uh if it was
transitory or it's no big deal
then
maybe they wouldn't have the political
problem that they have did you see the
quinnipiac polls the president's at 33
approval um
look at some of these other polls uh do
you think the economy is getting better
getting worse or staying about the same
worse at 54
this has become a political issue the
other thing is
what did we do in the united states it
might have been different from other
places if if all this was because of the
pandemic you would expect europe for
example to be experiencing the same rate
of inflation and they're not what was
different here it was all the extra
money that we put in what was when you
said that they have to do something
about it well all of a sudden now what
did you hear from them again today
that you have to pass build back better
in order to deal with inflation
that's obviously that's also not going
to happen joe manchin has already said
it's not going to happen but the other
thing that they said they would do greg
is perhaps ask for more
coveted relief money when you have all
this money sitting in the states that
hasn't even been spent yet yeah what a
nightmare crazy uh jesse you know we
were sold that uh joe biden was gonna be
like a comfortable sweater turns out
he's like a hair shirt
things have not gotten better they've
gotten worse
and i blame you
you have approximately three minutes to
respond um i'm gonna need a little more
time
so yeah joe biden said that this
inflation was just going to be a bump in
the road but when you're 80 and powerful
and wealthy
everything looks like a bump in the road
right that's why geraldo said ah this
shall pass i mean a bump in the a bump
for biden is like a crater for most
americans yeah i i think hunter probably
just was thinking did someone say a bump
for a bud no okay um but he needs to be
like more like bill clinton right i feel
your pain
just your pain don't feel everything
clinton felt but he needs to acknowledge
at least a little bit that there is a
lot of economic anxiety out there
instead of just cherry-picking facts to
make this look like the hottest economy
of all time the feds screwed up they
froze last year they should have raised
rates now they're going to have to raise
them but biden bucks
and the coveted relief package 2
trillion they basically set off a grease
fire in the economy and that's why you
have a dollar that's just been destroyed
and mayor pete needs to get back to work
did he hear what happened to me
rib eye gate yes they don't have bone-in
rib eyes secretary i had to get the
boneless rib-eye americans are suffering
look we're not used to scarcity you
understand that right you go if if a
person outside this country went to an
american supermarket yeah they wouldn't
believe what they saw you put on a
fitbit and you walk through every aisle
in a supermarket you're doing a half a
mile gut felt it's a palace of produce a
mecca of meat they have tables of cheese
all the eye can see i'm getting hungry
just now talking about it the only time
you ever actually see an empty shelf is
when people are stocking up before a
hurricane or when idiots like me buy
toilet paper in the first week of a
pandemic we're not used to it yeah no
only a democrat could bring us back to
the days of scarcity judge last word to
you who could have predicted this
uh i think i i said that that was the
last sentence and i'm glad you came
around to me because you know what i
want to say one thing jesse you were so
right i mean i remember i remember it
was 70s or the 80s you'd hear about
russia and they had empty shelves and
people standing in line waiting to get
food i never in a million years thought
america would be in a situation where we
had empty shelves it's shocking yeah
well
thanks obama
coming up the media's sudden epiphany on
the pandemic they're just waking up to
what we've been telling you for years
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else